Time is a concept that's fascinated
philosophers and thinkers throughout
history. The 5th century Greek
philosopher Heraclitus said time is a
game played beautifully by children.
Albert Einstein said time is an illusion.
We've never really understood what it
was and least of all understood what it
is in complex systems. This project seeks to develop models and tools and
frameworks to address the many faces of time in the worlds that we live in. So
the arrow of time traditionally refers
to the increase of entropy or disorder
in a closed system. The adaptive arrow of time relates to the increase in order
that's functional in an open system. In
complex systems there are multiple
arrows of time: there's an arrow of time
in your cell, there's an arrow of time in
a kidney, there's an arrow of time in an
ecosystem, and those are the complex
arrows of time. They integrate over many
adaptive arrows of time. The adaptive
arrow of time relies on entropy because
the increase in order in a complex
system has to correspond to an increase
of disorder in the world. And so this
project seeks to bring all of those
arrows together and we call that "complex
time." One of the foundational differences
between complex systems and simple
physical systems in relation to time is
that complex systems can perceive time
whereas a solar system for example, or a
planet, exists within time and we explain
processes for example of radioactive
decay as unfolding in time. There's no
sense in which that system encodes time
and uses it adaptively.
An issue that everyone cares about is
whether failure of a system is gradual
or catastrophic. It's a given that we're
going to die but it's not clear how. Can
we maintain function almost impeccably
and perfectly for a long period of time
and then collapse quickly, or do we have
to degrade painfully and slowly? We have
no theory for that, and this is an area
that we are actively working on in
relation to brain function. Could you
maintain almost perfect brain function
up until the end, or is senescence
inevitable? Can we control how long we
live? Could we predict and intervene to
ensure that a company would survive many
more years? Do we know when our
civilization is going to come to an end?
Are there early warning signs? And if we
can detect them are there mechanisms
that we could deploy to change the
trajectory of the system?
One obvious difference between the aging of technology and aging in biology is
that technology tends to accumulate more error, whereas biology tends to eliminate
error through death and extinction. So
when you consider software, every time
there's a bug you don't throw away all
the software. You add a patch. And so an
interesting question is, does software
and technology age in a fundamentally
different way from biological species
and biological organisms? Because you
can't afford to throw everything away.
Because you have to work with what you
have and fix it, and that leads to
extraordinarily messy and kludgy systems
which makes technology and society look a little different from the biological
world. Another important difference in
the aging of society and organisms is
that societies are made up of many
organisms all contributing ideas, all
contributing technologies, and so we have to have a collective theory of aging, not
just an individual theory, and that's
something that we certainly don't yet
have. One very intriguing similarity
between for example the power grid and
the nervous system is that catastrophic
failure in both cases can be explained
by contagion across networks, and so in
in both of those cases –in one case you
have systems of electrical connections
and the other ones axons and synapses –
damage propagates across the neural net or the power grid, taking down individual
components in a very statistically
regular way, so that when you look at
these two systems through the
appropriate mathematical lens they look
very similar.
We're very interested in partnering with
individuals or labs or institutions who
have highly resolved temporal data that
contain some signature of the arrows of
time. We're looking for economists,
archeologists, anthropologists, computer
scientists, mathematicians, physicists, and so on all who can come together and
explore the way time plays out in a
variety of different complex systems.
Because we have all of these different
communities working together, we can
begin to ask how time in one system
relates to time in another, for example
what is the relationship between sleep
and susceptibility to disease? What's the
relationship between brain failure and
sleep? What's the relationship between
the perception of time and the structure
of our society? So there are all these
much larger questions that we can begin
to address that could not be addressed
in a disciplinary fashion, as a
consequence of having all of these
communities working together to discover the core patterns in their data and the
common tools that they can employ. In
some sense what we need is to extend
statistical mechanics to include
heterogeneity and adaptive processes. And
this is a huge challenge because the
tendency has been to use the tools that
we have on problems where they are not a very good fit. And so a big part of our
initiative has been to bring together
theorists who are willing to explore the
full richness of the data and develop
new tools and frameworks that are
adequate to explain the regularities
that we observe.